hey guys this podcast is brought to you
by me today it's brought to you by me we
got merged up in the park and on the
what do you call it Chris D'Elia calm
we got congratulations podcast shirts to
go there and you can support the podcast
and I got other shirts and [ __ ] from my
stand-up and all that mm-hmm
I got upcoming shows in Nashville I got
some excuse me in Raleigh North Carolina
I'm gonna do a bunch of [ __ ] like that
and Austin that's pretty much sold out
and Australia and all of EIN California
and thanks for watching man on fire
again it's been out for two weeks and
I'm loving your tweets and all that [ __ ]
you guys are the best really appreciate
it thanks babies this is congratulations
the podcast episode 20 24 that's awesome
man who would have thought five long
months ago that today would be here and
we'd be on our 24th episode isn't that
amazing we are I'm in a good mood today
so hopefully we'll fire out a good
podcast I think so far I've had like two
bad ones if I do say so myself
but I don't know whatever I'm here with
my cup with my coffee ready to go and do
the podcast and and all that I have by
the way I'm at I I go to this coffee
spot you know about it mmm not gonna get
into that but what I am gonna get into
is they have a you know that like I get
the coffee it's got a [ __ ] coffee
place in the in the in
it's a parking lot for the coffee place
that's really all that's there okay so I
go on the parking lot in the coffee shop
I get the drink and then I leave and
there's a [ __ ] there's one of those
they have the you know those please
don't back up or your tires going to
[ __ ] explode like the strip that like
you go forward but then don't reverse
because you'll and like first of all why
have that anywhere even like a
government building or a bank or like I
don't understand why you would have the
please don't back up tyre knives in your
[ __ ] pavement so I so I pull out of
the [ __ ] parking lot and then well
you know what actually my friends still
in the parking lot I want to say bye to
him I go to reverse oh [ __ ] I just
wanted to say bye to Kevin the [ __ ] is
the deal why why okay and for the coffee
shop Hey Dude what's the [ __ ] big
deal if I want to reverse two more feet
why do my top why do you need to shred
my tires there isn't that like a bit
[ __ ] overboard like where are we
[ __ ] Afghanistan I've got ice on
we're the [ __ ] are we that we need that
oh dude when you get it when you get
this [ __ ] coffee and you leave your
[ __ ] dead to me
and if you try to come back dude you
better come out back the right way
there's [ __ ] three entrances for it
and you can't go through one because of
the [ __ ] tire spikes that's the
dumbest [ __ ] ever
hey invent something batter invent
something
it's useful dude there was one eye I saw
one but there was one that was like a
Subway sandwich in a Radio Shack the
[ __ ] the big deal oh dude I'm gonna go
anyway I goddamn want to in the in the
in the hey you RadioShack and your
Subway sandwich it's not damn port I'll
reverse in god that makes me mad
don't tell me which way I can't [ __ ]
go bro you get this [ __ ] coffee and
you leaving you don't come back you
understand me if you do we shred in your
tires Hey Dude what just pull me out of
the car and [ __ ] machine-gun me like
the scene in The Godfather with never
remember anybody's [ __ ] name on this
podcast what are you trying to buy a
frickin washer and dryer and leave in
Las Vegas
what the [ __ ] a James Caan I can never
remember my friend Brent was like you
never remember names in the podcast and
now of course that doesn't have again
yes sunny from [ __ ] Godfather do that
that's what should happen when you
[ __ ] pull out of the thing and you
want to go back oh you reversed get the
guys you get out still shooting even
though you're gonna die you with your
coffee just holding it so it doesn't
spill cuz it's too hot you don't want to
get burned even though you're getting
shot in the chest and head that [ __ ] as
dumb as [ __ ] don't put those strips in
anymore I wonder what the real logic is
for that like - it's probably the syphon
traffic out of there but it's not so no
traffic really in the only [ __ ]
parking lots that have this [ __ ] don't
like it don't like it don't like it
I don't know and I promise and after
that I went to my I have my buddy
staying with me for a few days in my
house and hey hey yo man can you type
ladder please one firearm dude my
producer is typing the louder than [ __ ]
it's like he's got Hulk hands one fire
[Music]
like we're wood wood [ __ ] Woodward
and Bernstein just all the President's
Men one fire so we so I took the
dry-cleaning to the [ __ ] my so I kept
on telling my buddy to his stay with me
Joel too [ __ ] close the door and he
didn't and so my dogs went in there
pissed on the comforter now it's one of
those comforters that don't
unzip and [ __ ] it's just the whole thing
so I brought it into the dry cleaning
today and the lady was like I love how
sometimes people just like like I bring
it in and it's all [ __ ] blanket by
the way how big of an idiot do you look
carrying a [ __ ] big-ass comforter out
out like on the road but there's only
one way you're going only one place are
going to with that and that's either
home cuz you just bought it but then
it's in some like Dexter cellophane wrap
or if you're just holding it though like
and it's so big when you carry a [ __ ]
comforter to like anywhere outside of a
house you look like your [ __ ] jackass
cuz it's so big like it's so big you
might as well be holding a boa
constrictor like that's how it looked
that's how awkward it is it's so hard to
carry a [ __ ] comforter you need like
seven people so I brought it into the
dry cleaners because they had piss on
the edge real cool it's white so part of
its yellow now it's real great and and I
brought it in and the lady was like
first of all they're never there right
you walk into a dry cleaner they're
always in the back have somebody and
look at them from have somebody in the
front they're always in the back and I
feel like they're back there playing
oona and smoking like just like ladies
just like just so weathered
and so like um over life and this is
their business and so I walk in and of
course like it's loud scared the [ __ ]
out of me while I'm holding the
comforter just like you know how about
this thing but yeah but some of them are
[Music]
and you're like I mean imagine hearing
that all day so I walk in with my
comforter trying to hold it up off the
ground even though it's just gonna get
washed and I walk in and she's like hi
do you have a comforter or duvet or
whatever and I was like I don't know I
just want you to wash it the dog's
pissed on it and she said all right this
is the [ __ ] oh it's going to be $30 and
like why why I just said yeah all right
fine but like why is it $30 you know if
I was like yeah it's gonna be 15 though
she'd probably be like okay like they
just throw the price out there do it
it's cleaning you're cleaning it I'm not
buying a [ __ ] thing that costs a
certain amount of money I mean I know I
know in essence I am but like oh she
looked at me like oh it's gonna be 30
like oh [ __ ] man I'm sorry you're not
sorry you made up the price you made the
price you're not sorry and I said all
right cool and then my favorite thing is
when do you need it by I need it when
it's done and I needed to be done the
quickest you know like what do you mean
when do you need a pie I need a I
definitely need it by [ __ ] February
2018 but can you do it anywhere quicker
and then they're just like how about
Wednesday sure when do you need it by
that's a comforter is it my medication
hey dude is it lexapro
I got a question for you when do I need
it by well take a look at it can you
crush it up and fit it into a tiny
orange bottle with a label on it that
says lexapro and can you put a twisty
cap on it or is it a goddamn comforter
give it to me when it's done and
whenever it's done
it's okay when do you need a bike sit
much I'll two thirty after school I
don't know you know just tell me when
it's gonna be done and I'll be there mmm
tried to get this [ __ ] app though
that does it they come to your house
like a piece of [ __ ] and you today -
comforter and they and then they bring
it and then they bring it to the thing
and they directly and they give it back
and I tried to download it it's called
cleanliness not even available in my
[ __ ] area if it's not available in
Los Angeles where the [ __ ] is it
available that's not cool expand your
[ __ ] and then it was funny cuz then I
would I took my dogs to the coffee shop
right before they got [ __ ]
dingleberries in the back of their
[ __ ] and they're like sitting down
like they don't give a [ __ ]
like I'm like on my other comforter so
basic I just got [ __ ] and piss all over
my house but so so I [ __ ] had the so
I'm sitting there at the coffee with my
dogs in this groomer this mobile groomer
drives by and I I drew that or I am what
I call it I took the number down cuz I'm
now I'm just gonna have the guy come by
and clean my dogs I'm like I'm putting
it we're all turning into the most lazy
[ __ ] of all time hey I want
post mates to come in and put the food
in my mouth and another guy to [ __ ]
manipulate my jaw so much so I chew the
overall rich that's how rich I want to
be have a guy put food in my mouth and
have another guy moving my jaw up and
down while another dude is sucking me
off not because I'm gay but just because
I have
lots of money and that's what I want
it's a gay definitely you know what else
did I watch what else did I do
I watched the oh no you know what I
wanted to talk about I keep seeing these
billboards for the show called will
first of all like goddamn [ __ ]
dude the the the the the [ __ ] suck
[ __ ] that came up with the title
will okay first of all the billboards
all over LA it's a show about it okay
the billboard is it says will
it has a young good-looking guy on the
[ __ ] thing and he's looking at you us
like he's about to be inside of us
alright so it's called will it's on I
don't know what its TBS or TNT or some
[ __ ] I have no idea it's probably TBS
because they know drama or tint he knows
drama TBS is where it's funny or
whatever the [ __ ] it's probably neither
of those but it's about young William
Shakespeare hey it's a show called will
about a young William Shakespeare dunk
dude all right look man first of all we
got a stop we've officially jumped the
shark on origin stories alright I get
Marvel oh yeah he was bit by a spider I
fell in a vat of plutonium he a cartoon
character origin stories are cool you
know why cuz you can make up whatever
you goddamn want hey it's [ __ ] gay man
why is the guy so gay Oh cuz he got
[ __ ] in the butt 12 times when he was
11 how cool that's interesting
also fell into a vat of plutonium and
now he's super strong and [ __ ] all guys
oh really cool made it up okay I'd watch
the [ __ ] out of that show by the way
gay guy but dude no by the way for sure
and get in trouble for that but dude if
yo what was the other one genius about a
young Albert Einstein dunk dude why the
[ __ ] would I want to watch a show about
the guy who became famous for this [ __ ]
that he does before he did it I want to
watch the guy doing what he does when he
does it and calling it will
oh those [ __ ] [ __ ] dude for real
callin it will like yeah you know what
it's simple call it well it wasn't
William Shakespeare yet he was will
cooks dude come on man
yeah well you just call it will and then
someone's like that's it it's so simple
cooks I mean it drives me nuts genius
it's about by the way I'm sure it's a
great show those guys are that guy's a
great actor who plays it Albert Einstein
but dude [ __ ] oh it's about [ __ ]
Albert Einstein at when he's 20 I buy I
want to watch a show when he's got the
crazy hair and the mustache that looks
like a goddamn broom
oh he's young and handsome good dunk
everything is a [ __ ] origin story now
no that really is like when comic book
movies start to influence the [ __ ]
actual shows about real people that's
when we've jumped the shark
no more origin stories I want to like
even the Steve Jobs one it's like just
show me what it's like when he makes a
[ __ ] computer you know oh he's young
oh you put on the [ __ ] mock
turtleneck the first time huh oh cool
nah don't show me what it's like when he
plugged in the [ __ ]
brick computer that was beige and you
had like 11 of them in your in your
classroom and it was only colors of
green on the screen of Dilli I don't
want to see that she had a show me when
I want it here's I want the movie to
start go wait have you see it in the
[ __ ] it you know when you start out a
Mack and his gun I want it to be like
that anyway I should it's up and running
and then wait I'm laughing because the
[ __ ] thing you remember you ever seen
the [ __ ] thing on online it went
viral but it was like when the guy when
they put it on the surround sound and
they turn on this computer and it like
woke up the whole office do you ever see
that anyone like gum and it was so loud
and everyone like [ __ ] themselves
yeah oh yeah it kept going it kept going
and going
[ __ ] that's how I want the [ __ ] Steve
Jobs movie to start and I want him to be
already 42 we'll name him
Steve no no I want that scene oh he's
got your eyes
let's name Young Shakespeare William
[ __ ] your origin story
[ __ ] your origin story I don't know I'm
by the way I'm you know people think I'm
hating I'm not hating I'm joking um I
don't want to watch a show about a guy
when they're young though that's you
know everything but he's getting so
young show me a [ __ ] man show me a
woman I've been watching I started
watching the show strength the strain I
was like I saw when I saw the Statue of
Liberty with the tongue coming out of it
on the billboards I was like gah watch
they what the [ __ ] that all about you
know the Statue of Liberty doesn't have
the tongue coming out so you know was
symbolic but I had to watch it and I
liked that Corey Stoll guy I think he's
[ __ ] cool there aren't many men like
actors now you know there's a lot of
like [ __ ] ass pretty boys and this guy
is just a man and
i Kim Corey Stoll shout out and so I
started watching that show that's what I
want to what I want to watch show I
don't like I was talking about it and I
don't want I don't want I don't want to
watch this show where like people are
like like we're it's so dramatic and oh
no and I'll [ __ ] someone's dying and
sort of someone's crying on a bench I
want to watch the show where I'm like
where I'm where I go where like every
two episodes I go like this oh that's
what I want to watch that show oh it's
that guy put demons in it you know put
demons in the [ __ ] show put a zombie
in the show put a bad guy in the show
all these shows where people are just
sitting around and oh it's real yeah
suck my ass ah but it's real though oh
yeah put a demon in it no no but it's
about put a demon in it yeah but this is
more about a guy and a girl and how they
really put a demon in it yeah no I know
but this is the you know the single dad
and then he's looking for anything so
he's got to do put a demon in it yeah no
I understand that but this one is about
the economy and how it's really put a
demon in it no I understand but this is
about women's rights and it's
interesting because it takes place and
that put a demon in it
oh is the woman a demon no have someone
biter maker it demon hey here's what I
want for all the [ __ ] shows where
people are just sitting around talking
running around riding a motorcycle and
nothing's [ __ ] happening and by the
way that's not a that's not a dig at a
what's up move what's a show anarchy
that's a Joe should happens people are
shooting in fight niche and [ __ ] like
that but goddamn [ __ ] shows
were those like a mandolin playing in
the background
put a demon in it take
[ __ ] mandolin soundtrack out that
goddamn thing buidling thumb or
ding-ding-ding he met her oh really he
met her have a biter
make her a demon oh dude drives me nuts
life you know you ever feel like that's
what I want to happen right there no
wait what this is episode 7 why is there
a demon and then he gets bitten and then
and then he's a demon by take your
mandolin shove it up your [ __ ]
by the way there shouldn't be mandolins
unless you're on a [ __ ] gondola hey
if you're on if you're floating in water
play the mandolin if you're in a studio
take the mandolin walk down the stairs
get into your car drive over to the
nearest body of water get out of the car
grab your mandolin walk into the body of
water keep walking till you drown III
don't know what it was in like 99 there
were like 75 movies that came out with
[ __ ] mandolins in the background and
it was just like alright I get it you're
quirky [ __ ] [ __ ] it you Corky alright
cool demons every show that's boring is
[ __ ] about anything any any show that's
about someone dying or like people
hanging out or somebody [ __ ] is a
mailman mother [ __ ] put it I'll tell you
what in like the fourth episode there
needs to be a demon in it or a vampire
or a werewolf or a zombie enough with
this [ __ ] oh that's a slice of life oh
really
take a slice of macaque and put it in
your mouth are you shows about a slice
of life cool I live life don't need a
slice of it got the whole thing take a
slice of macaque and put it in your
mouth [ __ ] he talking about oh it's a
slice of life cool life sporran take a
slice of macaque put it up your ass
over and over again I mean come on the
audacity of someone to say hey I made a
slice-of-life film oh yeah take a slice
of these lemons put them in your eyes
come on dude put a [ __ ] demon in your
slice of life movie god damn man
come on slice a life my [ __ ] only
thing there should be slices of pizza
hey there's a movie of pizza No then
don't make a slice life movie put a
goddamn demon in it for [ __ ] sake
slice of life is it oh dude is it locks
no this is a cake is it a birthday cake
or is it a movie with [ __ ] or is it
or is it the real movie that's
understated comedy tonally with Ed Helms
ah that's not a cake cool put a demon in
it make him eat at Helms [ __ ] if I do a
slice-of-life movie dude throw me out
the back of a Chevelle while you're
driving you like any movie that starts
with like that has a preview where it's
like meet ed or when your best friend's
lover is your lover's best friend put a
demon in it have them eat the lover have
meat the best friend having meat all the
cast when your best friend's lover is
your lover's best friend this summer
fall in love all over it
good dunk come on dude and then the
movie makes 3.6 million dollars and
everyone's like well I don't know what
happened I don't really quite understand
it really you don't I understand it hey
what's out there
what we're out there what do you mean go
look out there
what no no out there you can't see
unless you go out there okay well where
I don't see it dunk the outside now you
can't come in the building all right
you don't [ __ ] back up the Brinks
truck with some mandolin playing
slice-of-life type movie
hey babies I want to talk to you about
helix look you're unique aren't you
yeah yar cuz you're not sad you're not
weird well well that's the thing you're
weird in a good way but you're unique
okay you're not some boring person you
don't want you don't walk like everyone
else you know talk like everyone else or
sleep like anyone else so why is your
mattress one size fits all this is a
cool thing man it's a truly customized
mattress that will cost you five to ten
thousand bucks until now helix go-to
helix sleep calm answer a few simple
questions and they'll run a 3d
biochemical biomechanical model of your
body through the proprietary algorithms
they developed with the help of the
world's leading Aragona mcc's and
biomechanics experts now definitely God
talk to helix about all those words is
what they mean but still the result the
most comfortable mattress you've ever
slept in helix customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality
dude sleep is everything man if you
don't sleep we get sick you don't get
sick and for couples they customize each
side of the mattress your mattress
arrives at your door in about a week and
shipping is completely free that's why
everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are
talking about helix sleep you have a
hundred nights to try it out and if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free and give you a full refund no
questions asked
go to helix sleep calm / congrats and
get $50 off your order right now
that's helix sleep calm / congrats for
$50 off helix sleep calm / Congrats hey
guys you want the best underwear in the
world straight-up I wear them every day
I got people hooked on them my cousin
texts me about these underwear that I
gave to him okay if you're texting about
underwear did the best underwear in the
world me undies every pair of my undies
is sustainably sourced and made from
micro modal a fabric that's three times
softer than cotton me undies come in all
different colors and patterns and they
release new limited-edition patterns
each month that will that always sell
out I get them and I wear different
patterns and I'm cool okay
and people think it's cool
take a peek of my underwear when I
casually lift my shirt up like a cool
dude and they're like what is that oh I
like that that's cool the different
colors i express myself this way
this month's patterns were designed by
the legendary 80's clothing brand cross
colors with names that live up to their
bold design and bright colors increase
deep peace you dig and the og that's
what they're like okay so you've got to
see them for yourself go right now and
you'll save 20% off the first pair and
receive free shipping only at me undies
dot-com saj Congrats there's a reason we
undies have sold over 5 million pairs to
date and I have 40 of them all right
you'll feel it when you put them on
trust me and if you don't love your
first pair of me undies they're free get
20% off your first pair plus free
shipping at me undies calm slash
Congrats
that's me andis calm / Congrats my
undies calm / congrats I know what's up
with all those words though my o Kanaka
brick canticle and a micro fan achill
and you put it in Jai ker manacle and
sustainable aníbal oh man but yeah I
want to watch it everything's I want to
watch these shows that were where you
get okay cool that's cool I dude I had
by the way I I had some friends over the
other day like you know not many and I
my buddy is like my buddy Zach is like
the the music guy you know what I'm
talking about
he's always like I heard this music you
heard this guy that's how he sounds in
my head a little bit you heard this guy
he laughs at everything dude it drives
me nuts like I'll say something like man
I really want a banana and he'll be like
like huh and I'll be like what are you
laughing I'd be like I don't know it's
funny but he he he I put on the music
and I just put on a Pandora station like
[ __ ] I don't even remember was like
the hits at today or whatever and we was
they were playing all like Fetty WAP
but [ __ ] or whatever and he was like ah
dis musik man why don't you put on some
other music we're not a good thing you
got Bluetooth I'll put it on my
platelets Hey and I'm like dude I don't
give a [ __ ] first of all there were like
six people there I was like dude I don't
give a [ __ ]
that's the worst guy to be by the way at
the party besides the guy that picks up
a guitar and plays in himself and then
ruins the vibe the guy who's like hey
put on some different hey you hey my
playlist hey dude jump off a bridge
you're where you are just chill don't
[ __ ] I put on a playlist what we're
gonna try to who you Stalin what are you
[ __ ] Hitler
we gotta control every song just let it
ride baby you're in a pool dude that's
what he would do
good God put it up put her and then and
then so I I put on just because I wanted
to not because he said cuz I said bro
shut the [ __ ] up let's just list it did
so what it is there's there's six people
here we're having a good time I'm not
changing that every time somebody
decides they don't like the song that's
playing with the music yeah so I told
him I so I fight so then I change a
channel not because of him just cuz I
wanted to and I put it on 80's music and
he was like oh this music I love this
song and I said I don't give a [ __ ] man
I don't give a [ __ ] every song that came
on after that oh man I remember this
song dude shut the [ __ ] up about music
it was so annoying see this is good
music this is it you you think I give a
[ __ ] about what you think about my
playlist I don't even give a [ __ ] about
it oh [ __ ] man you enjoy the music I
enjoy sucks lice macaque go make a
[ __ ] slice alike music the movie dude
that guy that's like the guy that comes
up to a
a with a request I mean obvious I'm not
a DJ but pro hey can you play crazy and
love hey can you play something from the
chainsmokers do you have churches turn
around turn around
hey dude why are we fate why you facing
me turn around if you make me play
something cuz you requesting it turn
around you got to get [ __ ] up the but
dude that's what should happen anytime
you say hey DJ can you play Tom Ford oh
you gotta get [ __ ] up the but now the
whole [ __ ] [ __ ] put on it could you
play a soundcloud rapper dude our [ __ ]
should be facing the same direction and
I should be behind you turn around
you gotta get [ __ ] up the but now
SoundCloud rappers hey SoundCloud
rappers do you rap or do you just draw
on your face a lot
hey SoundCloud rappers is your face
hey SoundCloud rappers is your face a
face or is it a billboard on the way out
to Covina hey dude SoundCloud rappers is
your face a face or is your face a
low-hanging billboard on the way out to
Westminster
why the [ __ ] are they I mean do they
just do too much hey guys hey guys relax
to it relax I like to imagine SoundCloud
rappers running like and sweating and
running so fast to tattoo parlours and
being like and while they're running it
they're like
and they gotta like they're like I can't
wait to get a 69 above my eyeballs I
can't wait to get an ice cream cone
oh I got such a good idea
I got I'm gonna get a tattoo that's his
kitty cat on my cheek I can't wait and
then I'm running mm-hmm I think you
[ __ ] teen I mean hey what the [ __ ]
are they doing oh yeah yeah yeah yeah no
you definitely don't give a [ __ ] I got
that Soundcloud wrappers I mean my
Mercedes Benz truck my mercedes-benz
truck mama said his band's truck mama
say this man's truck mama said his being
his truck mama said his barons truck
mama said his vans try mama say these
bands truck and with a [ __ ] Winnie the
Pooh on his temple mama said it's being
struck mama said he's been struck who's
it for who's it for it's happening
it's time for a segment and it's a new
segment but it's a segment we like to
call the most [ __ ] up Instagram post
all week and shout out to shout out to
the homies Steve and his wife
Malika Mollica for making that new
jingle they're really [ __ ] funny made
me laugh real hard the most [ __ ] up
Instagram post all week of the week most
[ __ ] up Instagram post of the week
sorry it's still new so we're figuring
that out now here we go
this is the most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week and now I don't say the
name says I don't want my people to
attack them cuz people can be ruthless
but here's a guy and it's a selfie which
is fine but it's in the mirror so uh-oh
now he's got the the credit card [ __ ]
thing on his self on his phone you know
he's got the back of it like to where he
didn't take it off so we could see his
Visa Visa credit card as a very stupid
in his backwards cuz it's an a' mirror
it's in the mirror not oh now he's got
hair which is fine it's great hair but
he's also shaved the sides of it now oh
no it doesn't matter but oh with all of
it okay and then he's completely ripped
he's suggesting
have ever seen and this is the this is
the quote that this is the card that
this is the caption first of all it's
written like like not all together like
it's like there's one line is one thing
and then there's another line and that
is another line I don't even know how
people do that on [ __ ] Instagram I
always try to do it never comes out that
way
how
do that your magic on Instagram so this
is what it says the first line is I lift
weights Nishat got that got that know
why cuz your body looks like
Thor then after that says I eat plants
Nishat everyone does that's the next
line then the next line is I meditate
done man
you know why it doesn't matter it's a
selfie then the next line is I drink
green smoothies this [ __ ] you already
covered that with the plants sorry your
being done dn't you being done then and
it's the fourth line and fourth sentence
now here's the next line I believe in
the universe and its energy in this [ __ ]
you know why because you got to believe
in it because those things are things
okay it's like saying I believe in the I
believe in a couch a pointless next line
I care about animals and the environment
oh really
in a sociopath cool I don't waste energy
on negativity oh when people say that I
get BRM because you're human and you do
everyone always has negative thoughts if
you don't you're robot if you don't
you're a [ __ ] lunatic everybody is
negative sometimes because you have to
be because if you're not then you can't
do what's positive you're [ __ ] dolt
the next one now this is the one that
starts to get my insides a little bit of
a [ __ ] MBR em okay I am human and
make mistakes
hey man you just made seven of them okay
you posted the selfie and you said all
these tripe [ __ ] things that have
nothing to do with the selfie and
they're all one each one of the lines is
a new line and you're not a [ __ ]
you're not TS Eliot okay I'm human and
make mistakes this yet you work out too
hard and then here's another one I am
Who I am
bye Hey Dude are you unless your Popeye
you shouldn't say that everyone is who
they are everyone is who they are and
you already said you're human and you
make mister
so again being done dn't constantly
here's the next one
constantly changing but remaining true
to myself can't be can't be he got
addicted sailfin but in one line I am
Who I am constantly changing but
remaining true to myself that's a bunch
of [ __ ] horseshit that literally made
me want to start [ __ ] in my pants
here's the next line it's okay by the
way too many too many man come out with
a book there's no one it's okay to live
a life others don't understand no it's
not not if you're a serial color next
line surround yourself with people who
do wow if you do that you end up getting
serial killed
hashtag thought of the day not one
thought many thoughts don't do that bye
dude change hey man change completely
change hey dude this is a cool post but
completely change consistently changing
cool keep going
are you consistently changing cool keep
going for a long time till you're not as
buff and you don't say all those things
I mean who are these people you know
guys probably super nice but also that
was the most intensed agree most of the
week god the guys who ripped he looks
amazing actually
he's a cool dude he's probably probably
a nice guy too and he's vegan how do you
do that so impressive honestly yeah
people work
art for sure huh that's good though she
going back on everything you just said
actually looking at this guy's Instagram
now it's impressive how strong he is
why do you want to be that strong though
I mean I well if you compete right
that's the only reason
if you're a guy who competes
bodybuilding great cool work hard I love
that if you're a guy that [ __ ] just
wants to be big and muscular and you
have like a job
EU weird that kind of guys are weird
that's always been weird to me I know I
never understood that but that kind of
person never understood it's like I
guess it's your hobby I guess that's
your hobbies being fit and [ __ ] it's
like what is it like I don't know I'm
supposed to think about what it's like
because it's supposed to be comedian and
I'm supposed to call for the funny
analogy but don't have one don't have a
brain power for it I feel like I get on
one or two good rants or every one of
these and then that's it and a Peter out
I'm gonna look at these hashtags here
congratulations congratulations pod I
like the people on Instagram though that
are like obviously famous for how they
look like because they're good-looking
and then they have to like sometimes
play the guitar on a post and Instagram
post
or like to show you a painting they did
cuz they're like remember though okay I
I can do things I'm a talented when
people get widely-known
solely for their looks and then they
have to make sure that they know people
know that they're talented
like yeah just be [ __ ] you know just
be just it's Instagram just chill you
can just be a good-looking person on
Instagram that doesn't mean that you're
[ __ ] nobody thinks you're not
talented although it does if you start
to do dumb dumb [ __ ] and then we see the
[ __ ] like the paintings aren't and
you're not talented you know just just
keep it real anyway let me look at these
congratulations POD hashtags here see
who's trying to game the [ __ ] and this
is funny
this guy write something that I [ __ ]
thought was funny here yeah his name's
Cory brettski at stallion underscore
Cory I got a [ __ ] hey man change
change it you're not no don't write
stallion unless you're a horse but then
he couldn't then you couldn't type with
the hooves hey why do wrestlers with
long hair always have wet hair that's
hilarious
actually that is true why don't
wrestlers just have [ __ ] dude if I
was a wrestler I'd have a long hair but
I'd have that [ __ ] [ __ ] Brigitte I
get a Brazilian blown blowout forget it
my [ __ ] would be beautiful I would have
fans like not like people I'm talking
about actual fans blowing on me the [ __ ]
would be so goddamn gorgeous and I would
[ __ ] I would come down on a wire and
you would see how beautiful my goddamn
hair was it will be like a Beyonce show
or Mariah Carey in her prime yeah
they're always wet google it that's
weird huh you know there's a guy with a
water bottle spraying them before he's
photoshoot also they're probably just a
sweaty mess because of wow the wrestling
oh here's something that's
he wrote Michael McGowan the sixth oh
hey man there's too many Michael
McGowan's in your family dude name
somebody Steve your thoughts on filling
the quiet with so what's new yeah dude I
actually don't like that at all okay and
everyone shouldn't and I think everyone
doesn't but people still do it cuz they
get uncomfortable but this is you I
don't like when you're already talking
and the conversations going well and you
haven't seen somebody in a few months
and in the middle of the conversation
when you're still you're already talking
and somebody does that and somebody says
oh so tell me so what else what's been
going on man what do you [ __ ] mean
what do you mean what's going on we're
talking dude so what at what what do you
want me to say what's not good what's
not good enough about what I'm saying I
just told you I [ __ ] been doing what
I'm doing what else man what do you want
what I've been robbing gold from banks
is that what you mean sorry my life is
so [ __ ] boring that you have to keep
asking me what's been going on when
you're hanging out and you're like
thirty minutes in so what man it's so
good to see you what else has been going
on hey when are we done telling you
everything that's been happening I don't
want to [ __ ] talk about what happened
I want to talk about like [ __ ] faces
and your outfits and you know you've
been [ __ ] you've been [ __ ] you've
been [ __ ] sucking you've been [ __ ]
and sucking you bought new pants what
happened dude don't [ __ ] tell me
about some [ __ ] about like yeah I
was gonna join this and then that
happened and then my buddies having a
kid the gonk do it I don't care about
all that [ __ ]
your buddy had the kid don't tell me
about it I don't want to [ __ ] sit
here and lose my boring [ __ ] tell me
you've been [ __ ] or sucking tell me
who you've been [ __ ] tell me who
you've been sucking that's the [ __ ]
in countries damn ill you been [ __ ]
tell me you been sucking don't tell me
about your friends kid by cabriole tell
me oh you been [ __ ] telling you but a
second
don't tell me about how are you Jay John
something Brown Timmy we been [ __ ]
damn iliyan been sucking but if you tell
me about your ex-girlfriend all good
I'll get irate unless you been [ __ ]
her sucking her where'd you come where'd
you come where'd you come round don't
tell me about your kid and I was in a
little league don't tell me about your
mom and her friends don't tell me about
your dad and I will travel to Europe
telling me waving coming did you use a
condom did you not use a condom
were you in a bed or a hotel tell me all
the things where you been [ __ ] ants
again but if you tell me about your
daughter and her mom then I'm gonna get
up and leave well then go [ __ ] suck
to come back into my hair was [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh my god you know dude do you get on
stage and do you do stand-up do you make
people laugh tell me about would you
said tell me about the jokes she said I
live a life of play all you got to do is
make me laugh and then tell me about
[ __ ] again that's all you got to do
definitely don't tell me about
things that you're in do like the Mets
oh you're into the Dallas Stars oh
you're in do a team in Winnipeg oh you
[ __ ] follow the Rancho Cucamonga
quakes I don't care
did you [ __ ] him in Saigon do you make
jokes
then just say him oh [ __ ] I just want to
sit across from somebody and I want to
[ __ ] talk about them right there to
their [ __ ] face man and I want to
talk about me I want him to make fun of
me I want to make fun of my life and I
want to make fun of them and that's all
I want to do do it goddamn [ __ ]
yeah my kids in young good gunky gunky
step outside the place get gunk gunk
gotta shut some doors on [ __ ]
man you think I'm not serious bro I'm to
parking this [ __ ] we got to shut
some doors on these [ __ ]
I love boring people by the way but just
let me [ __ ] make let's make fun of
all of it
[ __ ] dude loving it loving it loving it
loving it one time I was at a it's a
place I used to go to in in where I grew
up and there was this really old guy and
he was so pissed off always giving the
slices of pizza out and he was really
old in you know orange hair how come
some guys have orange hair hey man
diet brown or blonde you white guy with
orange hair oh cool hey why would you do
that
hey dude a real cool quest why would you
do that hey hey man hey a [ __ ] who
did your hair chester the cheeto where
the [ __ ] his name is Chester cheeto did
your hair um and he was doing it and his
wife was like this he was like some old
white guy and his wife was like some
Vietnamese lady of course cuz they had a
piece
to shop there's nothing more pizza shop
than a an older white guy and a
Vietnamese lady handing out pizza they
literally could be hanging out if they
hung out long enough a pizza shop would
be built around them if that happened
when an old white guy meets the [ __ ]
younger Vietnamese lady a pizza shop if
they stand around too long in one place
a pizza shop is erected around them for
safety and then and then they're like
what are you doing and they're like we
got to do this for safety you stood in
the same place for too long he's like
and he's like what if I leave and she's
like what if I what if we walk away and
they're like it that's fine but if you
stay in one place for too long we will
bring an oven in here and we will erect
walls and we will put Joe's pizza
outside of it we're if the guy's name is
Joe it doesn't matter we got it to tell
us her name we'll put a sign up so so so
I mean this is a loosey goosey podcast
man so he's to go there all the time
after school and he used to deal with
kids man he must have hated us [ __ ]
snot-nosed teenagers and and she gave
him the pizza once that I ordered and
she goes then she goes here you go
jeez it's hot in a little Vietnamese
accent and he [ __ ] turned around to
me and I heard him say and she didn't
but I heard him say I know it's [ __ ]
hot tell me about that [ __ ] when you're
sitting across from a man it's so funny
to think about how miserable this
[ __ ] orange haired little [ __ ]
guy's life was I know it's [ __ ] half
and [ __ ] like that happens in life and
you have the audacity not to tell me
those things and tell me about your kid
doing Little League tell me about
[ __ ] and sucking tell me about when a
pizza guy snapped that is Vietnamese
wife but don't tell me when you
our daughter started learning how to
play the flute Brown come on man dude
[ __ ] like that happen in your life I
know it's [ __ ] hot that happened man
oh [ __ ] oh and your mom moved out of her
house God tell me some [ __ ] man
oh that's a good more of these [ __ ]
game and his system so congratulations
Bob oh this guy said better they better
bring out the Brinks truck and
everyone's saying are you a fan of Chris
D'Elia
Isaiah Thomas and Dawn the Celtics I
guess but I think [ __ ] to change said
that or something I mean doesn't it some
rappers say um let's see some more [ __ ]
hear that [ __ ] wet wrestler had thing
made me [ __ ] made me laugh it's so funny
when everybody does the same [ __ ]
[Music]
alright somebody sit by the way somebody
sent me they said they were watching my
Netflix special in a polo with a big-ass
number on the on the high left side of
it because he because I was talking
about that on the podcast and he really
did he had at number 43 for no reason on
the [ __ ] thing all right well I think
I'm gonna wrap this [ __ ] up let's see
maybe good do one more here by the way
guys I have a blast doing this but I
will stop if you guys don't [ __ ] rate
and review it I really will
so tell your friends about a man tell
your friends about it and rate and
review it and tweet about it and put up
Instagram posts and [ __ ] and send the
links say hey listen watch his pocket
listeners podcast and do the link and if
it grows and grows I'll do start doing
video too because I was thinking about
doing that you guys are great
and [ __ ] I had a good time with this one
man this was a loosey goosey podcast
this was the loosey goosey one you guys
were my babies don't you forget that man
and don't you forget that you guys are
in my cult cuz this is really just the
beginning of a cult my friend said he
started listening in my podcast and he
was saying to his kind of cult like
what's going on and then I started
saying hey I'm starting a cult and he
was like oh [ __ ] which means it's a real
man and you guys are killing it you guys
are helping me out all I want to do is
sit in a [ __ ] cabin out in the woods
and [ __ ] to have teachings and
readings and [ __ ] and like you know nine
people I [ __ ] guys and girls not even
gay but just like because you're passing
your novel it's a Greek like how they
used to think that like doing that made
you a man um talk about talk about
[ __ ] and sucking and definitely not
talking about Little League you guys we
wrote this podcast all the [ __ ]
wheels fell off I'll see you soon Austin
I'll see you soon Austin tickets at
Chris D'Elia calm I'll see you soon
Albuquerque I'll see you soon Mont
Montreal
Charlotte Charlotte Nashville but a big
bada bang Bing Bing Bing Bing
I'll see all you guys rate and review
the podcast please if you haven't
watched my my special yet on Netflix
please watch that man on fire man on
fire and hashtag it all out man on fire
congratulations pod and help me back up
this [ __ ] Brinks truck before
Isaiah Thomas gets it alright that's my
money dude you guys are my babies and I
appreciate you a lot thanks guys
[Music]
tell me above again and tell me about
sucking but definitely don't tell me you
marry daughter played the flu